[Music]
did you know it's a whole 10 years since
ps+ began and to commemorate that here
are the offerings for July 2020
you can grab these bad boys from July
the 7th there's three this month please
leave a like even if you dislike the
games as it really helps me out but you
do you it's all good the first game this
month is rise of the Tomb Raider twenty
years celebration a third-person
action-adventure game starring Lara
Croft the core experience is based
around exploration puzzle solving and
that combat from assault rifles to
pistols and shotguns there are also
plenty of opportunities to implement
stealth combining that with some archery
skills to take out your foes silently
the story is an interesting little jaunt
in which Lara is committed to finding
out more about her father's legacy and
tracking down a lost city the 20-year
anniversary edition also comes with all
the DLC for the game which adds three
chapters to the story over different
scenarios this is a highly rated bundle
scoring as high as a perfect 5 out of 5
on game revolution and 9.3 out of 10 on
IGN definitely worth your time game
number two is NBA 2k 20 to serve this
will be an awesome addition to others
this will be about as useful as a
chocolate teapot much like FIFA and
other annual sports titles the core
experience remains the same with small
iterations each year but NBA 2k 20 has
many modes to keep you busy my career
mode remains a great experience as does
the GM mode - the huge appeal here
though is the real player likenesses and
the official licenses used throughout
reviews average is about 8 out of 10 so
it's a great game if you're into
basketball but you probably already have
it if you like this series oh well we
have an extra game this month Erica this
is a very interesting addition as this
is a real movie with interactable
elements to choose your own adventure
Erica is plagued by nightmares of her
parents and we travel back through her
life to find answers these games are
great with friends and family so if
you're stuck indoors with your fam try
your decisions do matter of course so
I'm going to make only bad decisions to
replicate my real life happy days
Oh a quick note we'll be getting a 10
years of ps+ theme in the PlayStation
Store in the next few days as well so
there are the games for the month of
July 20 20 and off in the comments it's
okay to be happy sad frustrated or glad
you do you I'm Adam from PlayStation
granade been a pleasure I'll see you
next time
[Music]